friendly another bison guy I was telling
him like I want to get a a PS uh PS4 is
just like look what I saw okay got me
and I'm like how does that work it's
easy they give you anything money
and they're like here you go you have
like three thousand dollars in credit
I'm like you got your PSO and I got my
PS I got a couple ps1s that's how they
[ __ ] you though
[Music]
there's this guy who is considered a New
York City fugitive oh no he's
successfully dodged the law for the past
the past year
and uh he was one of those guys who did
PPP loan fraud oh yeah a lot of people
still they're still cracking down on
these mothers we're gonna get their
money back right you know they lost like
a billion in like
um those covid checks that they were
giving out those stimulus monies yeah
they are whoever they is that's not PPP
though PVP is different that's a that's
a stimulus oh dude that's four beating
so officials say that this dude named
quashawn Burton croissant
that's a dope name oh what you do
croissant
officials say that Burton or croissants
in Brooklyn last year after fraudulently
obtaining over 150
000 in forgivable PPP loans from it's
forgivable man
and allegedly use multiple identities to
get cash out of an ATM at a New York
City Post Office Wow first of all I
think he gave up the wrong name and [ __ ]
like what's your name oh [ __ ] my name uh
croissant croissant what uh Berglund
whatever it is he was at a donut shop
[Laughter]
so he's been dodged in New York right he
he ran from Brooklyn
um and he ends up making his way down to
Florida and goes to Walt Disney World's
Animal Kingdom park
it's I wonder what that's like Animal
Kingdom park in October when Federal
Postal Inspector Jeff Andre spots him
because he recognizes while he was on
the teacup ride Animal Kingdom oh Animal
Kingdom that's Magic Kingdom they
recognize him because of an H tattoo
that he has on his neck he looks like
he's crying bro you recognize him who uh
this guy who basically works for the
[ __ ] Bureau or whatever oh for the
bureau Federal oh he saw it was an h and
goes that's the guy
you know how many black does I know with
h on their [ __ ] neck yeah I would
have never been like wait a minute
croissant
I don't know dude so uh this dude Jeff
identified Burton nah man I'm Bagel like
damn it
I Mr Bagel no Bagel Man Chris I'm my
cousin
sorry it's okay
we got sprinkles jelly filled what did
you uh yeah you know what now you're
making fun of me and I'm not and I don't
like it okay
so this guy gets uh you know id'd by his
distinctive H tattoo
right uh he gets reported to the cops
who show up to the Animal Kingdom an
hour later and they reportedly found him
with two family members while they were
sitting at a bus stop in the park he
wouldn't produce any ID and he resisted
arrest so they took him down to the
ground and later I did him via his
fingerprints to find out that this was
the guy that's how you do it that's
basically how you do it you gotta know
that some guy named croissants going
around you got to memorize their tattoos
because there's a lot of people that
have H's on their necks was he like hold
this and then he's like I got to Pringle
prince [ __ ] yeah
oh I like not sure how tall
I like your imagination but no hold this
in your hand right now fifth grade
imagination but no thanks that's not how
it works no that's yeah wrote it right
here they said hold this but it feels
like such a freaking like catch me if I
can scene you know what I mean this guy
just like was you know got fired
probably like you're out of this case
Johnson is like damn it and he [ __ ]
gives up everything and his wife go on a
trip all right you've done too much
let's go to an animal kingdom fine
you're right let's go and then it's
working trying to take his mind off of
work and he's looking at you right it's
like what the what and she's like give
it up you're not gonna do this on our
vacation [ __ ] ignoring everybody
pushing kids
[ __ ] you know but that's it man yeah
because he said he said yours is a fifth
grade imagination well you know not him
pushing kids out the way together sixth
grade mines was a sixth grade yeah you
take it easy dude I do a little [ __ ]
yours was an Adam Sandler movie yeah
dude I get a little act out an area a
little bit of slow-mo he's pushing the
kid out of the way grabbing his face and
[ __ ] like that I don't need drugs dude
I'm just I'm a drug on my own
but yeah that's how I pictured it what
do you think uh croissant's family is
really like go ahead and explain his
family tree his family's tree what was
yeah who was he there what was his
upbringing that led him to do PPP loan
forgiveness uh fraud you know I think uh
his family was probably like already
Shifty you know what I mean his dad just
was a [ __ ] dad who just [ __ ] dads
dude selling anything yeah you know just
like Hustler I know so he learned how to
just [ __ ] cheat the system be like I
know how to [ __ ] move and [ __ ] in one
day he's like you know what he was gonna
go pro buddy hurt his body you know yeah
yeah he was one of those guys he's well
I could have gone bro but yeah I got
shot you know they always got shot you
know whenever you got shot changes
everything your dream just you know you
know they get you're done run like I
used to right I was [ __ ] gonna I
would go Harvard I got shot you know I
was gonna go he's gonna go to Harvard
dude yeah a little guy got shot I mean
yeah yeah yeah by the way honestly like
how smart of a guy to do that though
with the PVP loans is that to me I feel
like that's difficult like I don't know
I could I can I try to apply for that
[ __ ] it's a double that show to me it's
like it's smart for you to do that and
then it's like you really come to
Florida like that was your runaway it's
like they won't extradite at Animal
Kingdom you know what I mean well I mean
he's not he's not brilliant in as as far
as like not to get caught but he's
brilliant to like do the so many people
were you hearing about so many people
they were like I could have done it
creating you know llc's out of [ __ ]
thin air saying that their business was
going under because of like XYZ metrics
so they got money that's what I'm saying
I grew up in the whole good I never met
a black dude that was like yo I'm gonna
[ __ ] write a paragraph and they used
to be like nah [ __ ] that you know I mean
I would never think that he would [ __ ]
like maybe he would create easier it was
really easy he's a Brooklyn criminal not
an Arizona criminal you know what I mean
they're different they're smarter New
York they got the New York Street Smart
you know plus how many times like
somebody like like oh [ __ ] dude I just
did this I made up this fake ass
business and I got this money it's like
word like how do I do that yeah you know
what I mean it's like dude you just got
to say this because there was a bunch of
people that got caught quick but you
already know there's a bunch of people
that haven't even [ __ ] been caught at
all you know what a dumb criminal I am
because I I I failed at being a criminal
because I did it legally so um my buddy
was like yo check this out man I bought
a half a pound of weed but from the
government's money and like no [ __ ] how
did you get it he goes there's a thing
called financial aid just sign up for
school
sign up for school and you buy and you
and you get like a couple Grand you can
buy weed with it you can sell the weed
and I'm like no [ __ ] and he goes yeah
and you don't even got to pay this money
back and I'm like so what I got to do he
goes you just gotta go to school ignore
some phone calls and you just gotta get
like straight A's and [ __ ] and I'm like
straight Haze that's it and I'm like all
right
didn't know that I just needed a c c
average right because he told me
straight A so I just believe him so now
we're both being students going to
college getting financial aid selling
weed on the side and then this guy's
like your life Mentor basically he
helped me turn my life around after you
build a business dude and getting
financial aid to support myself and then
eventually what ended up happening was I
transferred and I graduated I got a
business degree
Joe is a father he's looking at his kids
like you want to sell some weed once you
graduate college I'll give you all the
drugs you want okay son's complaining
about not having money for something for
a toys you looking for money sign up for
college
okay he's a very idiot gets a bunch lady
[ __ ] Jesus free money I don't know I
learned the financial stuff the hard way
dude I [ __ ] my first thing I ever got
like credit card was like
yeah they'd be ripping people off yeah
Latino [ __ ] dude what is that I just
paid off my PS1 dude
is that is that like some layaway [ __ ]
yeah some little it's like they give
them they give anybody credit because my
friends you know the bicycle guy I was
telling them like I want to get a a PS
uh PS4 is just like okay and I'm like
how does that work it's easy they give
you anything money
really and I went over there I didn't
know nothing
oh I do this and that how much you make
and I don't even I just said a number
like 80 000. I just said anything I said
anything I was scared I was like 80 000
I think that's a good amount they're
like okay you have an ID and they're
like here you go you have like three
thousand dollars in credit I'm like they
got your PSO and I got my PS I got a
couple ps1s that's how they [ __ ] you
though and that's when they [ __ ] you
because they're like oh you don't have
to pay like 20 a month I'm like that's
it
for like 10 years God damn dude you know
it's all interest and [ __ ] that's not a
good thing God damn
when you're young you don't know what
interest is it's like you got interest
in a girl that's all you know what
interesting like I got interested in her
he goes yeah well you got interested and
you're like really I was like well I'm
painting on time but that [ __ ] was like
I ended up paying like five thousand
dollars for a PS1 he says Christ it's
not like five geez that's how they get
you five geez I'm like but it was only
300. how's that work yo that's how they
[ __ ] up the poor communities though all
those check cash places the credit
places but we don't know about friends
and they stack on like 20 something
percent interest they do that on purpose
people hard man or they really really
hide it underneath the next line of fine
print where it's like no interest your
first like three months right and then
so you don't have the habit of paying
back and you just buy buy same with the
car lots hey no job no credit no problem
we got you and then so you buy this used
car for three grand and then you end up
paying 20 grand yes or you just get a
repo because you you're all [ __ ] you
know and then it's like dude they [ __ ]
people over good business strategy is it
though I don't know I don't I don't like
that kind of business where you pray
upon people that don't understand but
you don't have to pray hey bro that's
America you don't like it go back to
your God damn
God damn country song [ __ ] colors don't
run bro yeah that's right brother you're
really pisses me off you don't like it
you can get out I'll let that long hair
pass but don't bring up that negative
[ __ ] around here God damn it
America son [ __ ]
foreign